[Musique]
bon
je peux vous aider monsieur ça va allez
monsieur c'est gentil du coup fait
qu'est-ce que vous faites maintenant
chercher la clé n'a pas la clé en fait
là qui va tacler la highway non pourquoi
vous l'avez clé bas pour démarrer oui
d'accord vous voulez pas acheter le
scooter avant de démarrer 16e et sion ok
très bien je veux acheter un scooter qui
fait beaucoup beaucoup de bruit parce
que j'ai envie de faire peur aux gens
feu rouge d'accord on vend que des
scooters électriques monsieur ici
on dirait pas tous nos centrales et des
f1
vous avez du pétrole ou pas sur des
scooters va rien maintenant il faut
penser à la planète monsieur ouais quand
vous avez une prime écologie sur ces
scooters une prime oui oui comme le
football
c'est comme ça ouais ouais c demandeurs
oui vous êtes très très bonne heure mais
vous me répondrez pas vouloir avoir un
prix non je ne suis pas un client
facilement je disais non maintenant je
sais ce que vous proposez combien une
prime de 1000 euros
la moto à khan
vous allez prendre quatre scooters ça
fait un total de douze mille euros
je peux payer ans
en éolien
non comment
en argent qu enfin virement chèque a
comme partout comme partout
ok moi dans ce cas là je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pour aujourd'hui je vais
me contenter de reprendre dans l'après
way et puis je repasserai dans la
semaine pour
les véhicules
boss
gillet à lyon sur
les 110 véhicules pas de souci il est
bien ouais elle est bonne journée
monsieur avoue si monsieur
[Musique]